our next presenter is nominated for
playing a hitchhiking serial killing
prostitute
great just what we need another - it
ladies and gentlemen the most beautiful
monsters you'll ever see Academy Award
nominee for best actress miss Charlize
Theron
tonight's nominees for Best Foreign
Language Film come from places as varies
varied as Canada Sweden Japan the
Netherlands and the Czech Republic but
the beauty of this award is you don't
have to speak the language to get the
meaning of a great film the nominees for
Best Foreign Language Film are the
barbarian invasions from Canada denne
arkhan eel from Sweden Mikael hafstrom
the Twilight samurai from Japan Yoji
Yamada twin sisters from the Netherlands
Ben sama guard
Jill Ari from Czech Republic
Andre TRO young
and the Oscar goes to from Canada the
barbarian invasions accepting the award
the directors any arc home this is the
first Academy Award and third nomination
for Canada
we're so thankful that Lord of the Rings
did not qualify in this category
we'd like to thank the Academy we'd like
to thank the co-producer Fabian Vanier
Victor lui the Canadian French and
Quebec government for their support of
the film industry Thank You Angus
Monterey and Miramax Thank You Harvey
Weinstein for putting your heart behind
this film and shining the light on this
we really like to share this with you
and share it with the actors and the the
technicians who worked so well on this
film it's over my time is up as usual
thank you everyone se beaucoup at the
mall
mmm